good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope
everybody's having a gorgeous day thus
far hello Jacqueline how are you using
I'm using your uh your government name
my government French name
Jacqueline it's very French you're kind
of like Jacqueline Foley I kind of am
yeah except you would never do a
Jacqueline Foley did what'd she do take
the job that was given to her that was
rightfully hers
no she like you know she was fraudulent
and she was a part of a scheme that you
know undid Stanley Tucci's lifelong work
oh right Stanley suffered not cool right
and you like you have this kind of deep
connection to Stanley Tucci since that
one time you claim you sat next to him
on a six hour flight home from La even
though he was sitting in coach it was
comfort
and it was the day after the Oscars
Oscars so seats were hard to come by so
I understood by Stanley had to slum it
with the likes of me yeah yeah yeah I
agree but no I would never take
Stanley's job so no it is not in my
character
hmm so you're not Jacqueline filet is
kind of the message here I guess not no
do does literally anyone in your life
call you Jacqueline no
no one no I legitimately forgot it was
your name yeah it's just like my serious
name
but so underrated like you have like a
nickname you know yeah no it is really
underrated
you're just like one of those girls with
like a shortened like with it with a
government name yeah it was just like an
official name
how exciting yeah it's pretty cool I'm
very multifaceted you are I feel like
there's so many layers we're constantly
peeling back well we actually peeled
back some layers yesterday on the
patreon because we did a general q a
part two taking all of your questions
from across the board we talked a lot
about fashion we talked about shutters
wardrobes like what we love about each
other's wardrobes what we don't like
that was fun we did a bunch on like New
York City hot spots we were like you
know ran the gamut on all topics also
something that we never talk about our
favorite scents
yeah we talked a lot about scents
s-c-e-n-t-s because we're always talking
about c-e-n-t-s and how we can get them
and we're always making s-e-n-c-e
s-e-n-s-e s-e-n always we are always
making s e n s e yes yeah because one
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna make
sense yeah so if you want to learn more
about us check out the patreon and also
on the patreon episode we are kind of
tossing around this idea of mukbang
right one of our kind of most critically
acclaimed Vlogs we've ever done is our
mukbang from what was that now like two
years ago
yes that that's a very good perception
of time Claudia thank you so much and we
talked about perhaps doing a second one
hitting up some fast food chains we
haven't actually been to and yesterday
you know we did the work we routed what
what could be our potential mukbang
we're out and if all goes according to
plan today Jackie's gonna see my car for
the first time first of all and I'm
gonna scoop her up and we're gonna head
to some kind of tier two
chains not tier I don't know I don't
think they compete with like the
McDonald's is no tier two yeah because
last time we did McDonald's Burger King
Wendy's the the you know the trifecta
yeah so this time we're kind of doing
more Niche fast food here too I think
it's three places that we've never been
I've never been to any of these places I
can't remember the third place but the
two that I'm thinking of I've never oh
sorry the third I have been to so have
you what is it
oh I I've been there definitely
okay we're a human experience I already
know what I'm ordering me too so I'm
like not eating a lot I didn't have
breakfast this morning like I'm leaving
my belly full for the mukbang we're
about to film literally right after
today's episode goes up yeah I'm very
excited about that so join the patreon
so you don't miss it I did have a bagel
this morning because your girl's gotta
eat but don't worry I have room left
now can I ask you a question about
today's stories sure
do we have anything about the strike no
okay because I've been sitting on a
thought and it might be like an
extremely extraordinarily hot take and
maybe I'm just misunderstanding because
again I'm not like well versed in you
know unions and the picket line yeah but
then I saw this other video yesterday
and it really kind of
um
I don't know it's making me think and I
think maybe we should talk about it okay
I would love to talk about things in a
hot way did you see this other video on
tick tock
which yeah yes I thought yes okay and it
was from sag you know sag has social
media accounts and they are you know um
posting pictures and videos with
celebrities and you know just talking
about you know why we should care about
the strike and it's all pretty you know
it's good content
and I'd seen this conversation being had
before about influencers and then I saw
it come directly from sag and I was like
okay that's interesting
so I had seen this girl that I follow
who I love
um and she was just like she had never
made me think about it she was like
content creators I think she put it on
like her close friends version on Tick
Tock she was a Content creators like be
really careful now that the strike is
happening you might get opportunities
that you probably wouldn't have gotten
because you know none of the celebrities
or the actors in the films can promote
the movie so now you know studios are
looking towards other ways of promotion
that aren't reliant on the actors who
are in unions and who are now currently
striking so
she was just basically like by the way
like watch out like I know it might seem
you know tantalizing and exciting but
just know like you'd be crossing the
picket line and I think they call a
person who does that a scab it's like
like a deplorable thing to cross the
picket line even if you're not a member
of the Union right so I was like oh
that's so interesting I wonder you know
how content creators and influencers
play in this whole thing and then I saw
sag put up a video yesterday of them
outside 30 Rock one of their I think
someone who works for sag with bow and
yang and it was like a message to
influencers and creators being like you
know you guys you know might be getting
reached out for opportunities that you
never would have gotten but just know
like you know stand with the union and
you know a lot of influencers are in Sag
but a lot aren't they were saying they
have like an influencer contract so some
influencers are eligible for sag
um most I would argue are not in Sag and
it was just kind of reiterating the
point like stand with the Union
um we know you might be getting
opportunities that are exciting and
um new for you but just keep in mind
like you know we're all in this together
and it really made me think like why are
we all in this together like no no since
I'm genuinely I am genuinely trying to
understand like this is not I'm really
trying to understand so an influencer
who's like running a business who just
due to circumstances completely outside
of this influencer's control a situation
that has nothing to do with a random
influencer gets a work opportunity
whether it be money or um opportunity or
you know just like a potential new
exciting Adventure
um and they are being told like to stand
with a union that really has nothing to
do with them I'm and I'm not encouraging
influencers but it's like kind of this
conversation it's like influencers you
know remember don't cross the picket
line and it's like is it considering
crossing the picket line when the whole
situation has really nothing to do with
you or your line of work
well I guess yes it's considered
crossing the picket line but when you
ask like why are we all in this together
I think that's just like you know a
blanket statement it's like just stand
with the strikers because
in their purview it's the right thing to
do right
but I don't know if you've never been a
member of stag if you wouldn't have
gotten opportunities before and like sag
wasn't giving you opportunities
it's every man for himself honestly
right that's it's just like a
conversation that I'm seeing being had
and I'm like
I like I guess but what's you know ever
everyone in Sag right now is trying to
do what's best for them and their family
get themselves you know the best sort of
situation the best setup the best
royalty deal so that they can continue
to work make a livable wage I totally
understand it so isn't that influencer
just content creators in general just
also try to do the same thing for
themselves yeah and then I guess in sag
their cause just doesn't seem as Noble
right right no I thought it was like so
interesting and I'm like I I wonder if
anyone else is thinking this or am I
completely wrong like is there an
element of this I'm not understanding no
I feel like you're understanding it but
it's just like you know harsh truths
right okay
um and also if someone who's not
affiliated with sad like an influencer
does cross the picket line like
and they're a scab right well then what
happens like I do believe that you are
then banned for life from ever joining
sag
oh no I don't know if it's like that
with sag I know it's definitely like
that with wga the writers Union okay
yeah so it's like there are consequences
for
um
for not standing with a union you are
not affiliated with whatsoever like that
to me I just I'm I'm really not
understanding no no okay so you can't
join tag okay
no but I think for a lot of content
creators influencers there are
opportunities for them in their future
if they grow that you have to be a sag
member for like you could get booked for
a role they want you know content
creator Ashley to play something in SVU
or whatever you cannot take most like
Hollywood roles if you are not a member
of sag it's like a requirement to be in
the union
interesting so it's it's layered it is
layered I think everyone just has to
make the best decisions for themselves
much like the writers and actors are
doing right
you know but if it's an opportunity of a
lifetime like if they want to put you as
the star of a feature film
right because nobody else is available
like I'm sorry but you gotta do it but
first of all that's actually not the
opportunities people are going to be
getting promotional promotional yeah
being paid and I think to be paid by a
movie studio is like one of the top most
prestigious like coveted types of brand
Partnerships for influencers and they're
very few and far between so I can see
you know an influencer who might not
have the following that usually is
required to get those sorts of deals to
be on the you know on the list of of
promoters now I could see that being
very you know
um tempting yeah I think just like
anything else you have to measure the
risk reward what's the opportunity being
presented to you is it worth
muddying the waters with sag and maybe
jeopardizing potential opportunities or
is in the future you know is this the
opportunity that you never would have
gotten even if you play by all the rules
right you have to weigh it for yourself
and like how important is being a member
of sag to you right dear influencer now
let me ask you a question what about
reality TV like there there was just
this like love Island promotional trip
um and they're promoting the streamer
peacock reality TV
I read like sag posted this whole big
like Carousel of things like what you're
currently allowed to do during a strike
and what you're not allowed to do during
a strike reality TV is a non-sag um
most reality TV I think is a non-sac
production reality TV will continue to
be like filming is is continuing
promotion is fine like it's totally
weirdly separate but a lot of reality
stars get opportunities after becoming
famous reality stars that require them
to be in Sag which is like when we were
talking about Lala Kent not going to the
MTV Movie Awards I'm pretty sure you'd
like to film that Uber One commercial
with Sheena you have to be sag so I'm
sure they've all been sagged for a while
having nothing to do with filming
Vanderpump Rules got it because they are
filming that imprompt worlds and that is
a story today great
okay well I hope that the strike is able
to oh and I would argue that in the next
coming weeks and months more reality
shows will go into production because
Studios
aren't making new content that's
scripted and they need content to film
all their streaming services so I would
argue we're going to be getting a lot
more you know selling Sunset Tallahassee
yeah yeah like it's giving covid you
know we're gonna get Spring House fall
house right we're doing you know we're
they're doing the best that they can
with giving the current situation now I
also spoke to some industry folk the
other day and they said that the strike
is expected to um conclude you know
sometime mid-september
and what happens in mid-september that
concludes the strike
nobody like is like hustling right now
to like make this was just what I heard
to make amends it's summer you know
people of extraordinary means are not
you know pounding the pavement trying to
you know put dinner on the table for
their families like everyone's summering
in Italy and by the time everybody comes
back late August is when everybody gets
back to work and once everybody's like
on board to like you know start making
money again it'll take a few weeks and
they'll figure out what what the deal is
you know
got it
now I think somebody could argue back to
what I was saying about influencers is
like what they're fighting for in Sag is
like certain things are kind of
universal like AI is a big topic of
conversation and I saw that like what
the studios want to do with the
renegotiation is like pay a background
actor because these negotiations really
aren't for the a-listers like they're
well compensated and sure could it be
better yeah but like they're making
hundreds of millions of dollars yeah
it's really for working actors who don't
have you know
big TV royalties coming in to set them
up for the future it's people who do
small roles like background actors and
they want to use AI to like hire a
background actor like let's say MTV
wants to hire background actor they have
them come in for like one day of work
film a bunch of different stuff and then
use AI to take this person's likeness
and put them in literally an unlimited
amount of background work which would
give them one day's worth of pay for
like a lifetime of content which is
totally unfair and so I think like a
argument is like well stand with sag
because whatever happens with sag and AI
could happen to your
um
job and Ai and it's this conversation
about like computers and robots taking
over for human jobs which I feel like
has been happening for a very long time
I feel like Amazon's a great example of
that you know no I mean Factory workers
yeah right have been replaced by
machines for years people are being
replaced by me so was there a call out
for the influencers to stand with the
factory workers uh not that I recall
so I just think it's a question yeah
also I mean it there it seems like
that's something that they couldn't
figure out it's like as much as you use
my likeness you pay me for my likeness
yeah AI can make me do whatever you want
but if you're gonna use it it's less
it's less you know yeah physical work
for me but they still have to iron out
the logistics of that and that's new
yeah so I understand why it's gonna take
a minute but I feel like there's a way
to make that work yeah even though I saw
a video today friend Drescher calling
what's the same Bob Iger a new word
she's been using kind of she's been
getting her thesaurus out she called him
an ignoramus
oh no she's kind of choosing like the
best words like I'm keeping a list of
all the insults for Andrea has been
slinging and I'm using them the next
time I get into a fight with one of my
friends repugnant ignoramus
it's just it's giving sandbox like she's
calling him these things because she has
a crush on him
no it's it's happily ever after it is
like the more she goes in like the more
the payoff's gonna be like we're 30
through the book they still hate each
other he's an ignoramus but they're 70
like don't worry they will get steamy in
the boardroom
it's so true also I the one concern that
I had seen but I haven't been keeping
you're really like kind of a sag-aftra
kind of Aficionado in terms of how much
you know about the strike but also that
like AI could write Scripts
and and that's what the writers started
that was one of like the writers for
scribes now the actors are a part of it
standing with the writers and the
background actors and their likenesses
and such but hey I could write a movie
script okay but like I doubt it would be
nearly like in order to write a perfect
movie you need things that AI does not
possess like heart feelings you know
what I mean I'm learning hardened
feelings
no still if I had like if I had to
invest you know in a movie I'm a
producer and I had to give you know my
hundred million dollars I want a movie
that was written by a person not AI like
I'm just I trust AI for a lot of things
honestly like the picture of William
with hair Perfection
um I don't trust him to make to write
scripts like about The Human Experience
you can't you literally can't you can't
know what that's like
they're learning I agree with you and I
don't understand how they could learn
emotions feelings like I literally don't
understand AI But like everyone just
keeps saying like they're learning and
they're gonna learn
well but you know what they'll never
[__] learn our sisterly Bond and our
sisterly ways uh 100
yeah so
I feel good you know job security wise
yeah and you know if AI wants to create
a version of the toast
that's another great podcast like hosted
by two robot sisters okay I would listen
to that 100
maybe we could take a few weeks off you
know
we could use AI toast for maternity
leave for maternity leave for like our
holiday break if any either one of us
gets sick you know yeah like some days
we're in studio some days it's Audio
Only some days it's an ai ai just like
throw it into the rotation Audio Only
video only AI
this is kind of Awesome
yeah as long as the episode's done stick
it up
yeah but then if they do then we also
like don't have to worry about AI you
know it's AI coming for our jobs yeah
it's kind of either they help us or they
hurt us
yep
damn AI big moral dilemma I heard it's
going to be bigger than the Industrial
Revolution really yeah I was reading a
think piece on how the whole world's
going to change more than we know like a
giant leap for you know not me but those
of us who might not be familiar with
what the industrial evolution is to
maybe want to give like a little um okay
Revolution pretty much like took us like
for hundreds of years we had like the
same means of tech not we didn't have
technology but the same means like
Transportation like how long were people
on horses and horseback for like
literally thousands of years and then
there was like a revolution with the
Industrial Revolution all of a sudden
with steel and trains and then we have
cars and electricity and all of this
happened like it was a giant leap Within
50 years like the whole way of living
completely changed and like how many
years were the Industrial Revolution
taking place well we could see when it
started
when it would like
Finish Well it's such an exciting time
to be alive it occurred during the
period from around 1760 to 18 18 20 18
40. so 60 80 years
all right it was a period of global
transition of human economy towards more
efficient and stable manufacturing
processes that succeeded the
Agricultural Revolution so that was uh
the last Revolution so I guess this next
one is the AI Revolution right well we
our kids will be reading about that in
textbooks right but I also feel like the
internet was a revolution definitely I
don't know if that one's like called
something
the digital Revolution the digital
Revolution it's crazy to go so like
we're so back to back with our
revolutions like it feels like digital
just happened now we're going into AI to
artificial
the artificial Revolution
not me I'm real
much like Simon vancampen I am real and
I'm intelligent
these are my affirmations I'm real I'm
artificial
I am real I am intelligent keep telling
yourself that girl keep telling yourself
that
um
stories I feel like we've got some
ground to cover we should dive into the
stories the fast five stories that you
need to know
and the fast five stories that uh you
need to know are brought to you by the
State Farm personal price plan they help
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences
so think about think about insurance
like this what do you do to your music
playlists your podcast feeds and your
social media Scrolls like what is all
about having common well they're a
reflection of you so you know my social
media is full of Taylor Swift content
clearly sag after related content
Jackie's is more Mama curated you know
diaper hacks we've both you know kind of
personalized our lives and that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about it gives you options to help
you personalize your coverage so that
you can protect what you care about most
at an affordable price just for you so
you can see more of yourself in
everything you love
so State Farm is out here personalizing
your insurance which is so revolutionary
and so like obvious because you know
who's who's more similar than Jackson I
nobody but even our insurance needs are
quite different you know I have one car
now Jackie is too Jackie owns a home I
do not so like a good neighbor State
Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
and let me just do that one more time
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
yeah
this episode of the toast is brought to
you by Poise Ultra thins becoming a mom
has come with a lot of big changes and
with baby number two on the way I'm
getting ready to experience some of that
all over again the joys of postpartum
life are boundless and thankfully we
have Poise Ultra thins which makes
things so much better so something super
common that we don't always talk about
when it comes to postpartum life is
bladder leaks one in two women over 20
experience bladder leaks and most young
moms try to use period pads to solve the
problem but actually period pads are not
designed for pee thankfully Poise Ultra
thins are specifically designed for
bladder leaks and keep you 10 times
drier than the leading period pad the
Clean dry and fresh protection these
pads provide is a lifesaver and they're
shaped to fit and flex with your body so
you can stay comfortable and live
without compromise Poise Ultra thins
offer with and without wings so you can
live worry free it's great to have the
things you need on hand for postpartum
life and things that are directly made
and tailored for all of the things you
might be experiencing so Poise Ultra
thins are that bad personally I have
enough on my plate as a mom so I love
the idea of taking one worry off the
list it takes Poise learn more at
poise.com about the Poise ultra thin
pads and how they are designed to better
help against bladder leaks in ways that
traditional period pads most certainly
are not
all right
okay our first story Little Vanderpump
Rules news little twofold because the
cast is filming and they have taken a
cast trip to Lake Tahoe the gang really
is all there Sheena Shea her husband
Brock James Kennedy Ali Luber Tom
Schwartz and Lala jetted off to Lake
Tahoe for a summer getaway it also
looked at
Sandoval was there yes Sandoval was
there a fan I was reading Twitter this
morning because this photo of everyone
who's on the trip including Sandoval
like arms around each other smiling he's
like not on the end of the group photo
like he's in the middle so ever almost
like quaking and Sheena responded
because someone was like looks like
you're getting really chummy with
Sandoval and Sheena was like actually
like a fan of the show came up and found
us and asked us all for a picture so
we're not gonna like all look miserable
for this fan we were just like you know
putting on Smiles which is actually a
pretty good explanation because I was
like damn everybody's looking real
chummy the fact that he's even on the
trip is just questionable crazy well
Ariana and Katie are notably not true
um and I guess this answers the question
of what is the vibe like for the next
season gonna be because it felt like not
a single person would film with Sandoval
yet here we are yet here we are also a
little Vanderpump news is that Raquel's
dog Graham is back with James and now
his girlfriend Ally uh they posted a
celebratory snap kissing um the dog
graham cracker and Ali and James he said
look who made his way back home back
into my life I'll take care of you
forever and I love you
that's so you know sweet and must be
really nice for James but it does you
know beg the question of Raquel's mental
state if she can't you know take care of
her dog yeah at first I was like well
maybe she's not home and like maybe
she's still in the facility so it's good
if the dog she's back she is back and
she's also like holding out on
negotiations waiting for more money so
I'm confused as like why now does he
have Graham yeah that's what I'm saying
like if this whole time Graham was not
with James while she was like away the
exact time he would need someone to
watch her dog while you're not home when
she returns the dog is then given to
James it makes me think like she can
barely take care of herself in the state
that she's in let alone a dog
I don't know what I don't think that but
I don't have a better answer so we could
go with that I can't think of anything
else literally the day we see paparazzi
photos of Raquel for the first time in
weeks after being in a treatment
facility she's out in La she's I guess
back is the same day James posted he
starts watching Graham yeah but isn't a
having a dog an emotional support and
companionship like a mental healthy
thing to do very true
it could be very good for your mental
health yeah or sometimes you're in such
a depression you could barely got out of
bed to take a shower let alone take care
of another living being that needs to be
fed and walked but the dog forces you to
get up and get out and she but maybe it
wasn't maybe it wasn't
maybe but that's really dark then
I know
well I'm happy for James that he gets to
spend some time with Graham
yeah I like
has a lot of family yeah and Raquel has
like a lot of family so the fact that um
she opted to leave the dog with James as
opposed to like a sister or her parents
um I actually think it's sweet you know
yes I agree so and I think the dog will
be happy and the dog's you know
well-being is of utmost importance as
well so
it seems good but it just begs the
question like why can't Raquel
what's going on with Raquel
it's so funny like there was such little
interest in Vanderpump Rules prior to
this Scandal and like after the peak of
the show like we never used to like
really get this much social media
footage of what was going on during
filming like it would all genuinely just
be a surprise when we started watching
the show no but now it's kind of like
it's kind of like Beverly Hills you know
there was so much news you know before
Lisa Rena left so much news coming out
while they were filming that we would
know what to expect yeah like the way I
would never have cared about where
Raquel and James's dog was living before
that would not have
signaled anything to me but no they're
really like a top tier reality show now
yeah well speaking I mean nominated Emmy
nominated speaking of Bravo our next
story Andy Cohen tells flirty Roney
starbrand Whitfield that Mauricio
umanski is available
Andy informed Brynn that Kyle Richards
recently estranged husband Mauricio is
on the market while on the red carpet of
last week's Roni Premiere he was asked
by a Marie Claire reporter which house
husband he thinks is the hottest he let
out a prolonged um but then he turned to
Brynn who was doing her own interview
and she said Mauricio with a smile and
he shouted back he's available
okay but he's not
like I literally just saw an interview
with Erica Jade and she was asked about
it and she actually had the most like
political perfect response she was like
I'm not gonna speak on it because it's
like not my business and I want Kyle to
be able to like tell her side of the
story but like they are together
and Kyle told Paparazzi she's like I'm
not single like they're together so I
don't know what Andy's talking about
okay so why put out this statement that
they're having a hard time like that
they're because it came out like in a
People magazine and then everybody
started reporting that they're getting
divorced like as if it was 100 factual
she's like We're actually not but if you
must know like we've been having trouble
yeah
she was I think she was like she didn't
do that unprovoked like she might have
even kept it from everyone if it didn't
come out in every single magazine that
they were hardcore 100 getting divorced
got it well then Kyle's not gonna be
happy with Andy about this
no it begs the question Jackie who do
you think is the most the hottest um
house husband Frank Catania
100 but I would actually say either
Mauricio or Evan gold Schneider and I
don't know if that's only because
they're both like the Jewish Kings and
that's just what I'm attracted to but
they really are both like the most
handsome yeah no they're both incredibly
handsome I think those would be like
classic popular answers yeah Evan
goldsteiner I feel like is a little
underrated because Jackie got demoted
yeah and because he hasn't been on the
show for like a million years yeah but
that's a good one honestly all the
Jersey husbands are yeah so great but
let me just make sure I'm not missing
any
other husbands I mean I'm sure you know
someone done around a hottest husbands
housewife like who are we forgetting
somebody like so obvious it's always
Mauricio people say oh people say Harry
Hamlin
oh I don't think he's hot people say um
Harry Hamlin okay they also say Jeremy
Locke who is Deandra Simmons's husband
and I actually agree he was very hot
Eddie Judge okay oh Denise Richards
husband Aaron he was cute but his
personality ruined it it's hard when
it's like someone who hasn't been on for
that long like I don't know them
enough you know but like we know
Mauricio we know Frank of course Joe
Gorga Todd Tucker whose Candy's husband
oh Juan Dixon is on this list I don't
disagree I mean I don't agree Harry
Hamlin I do not find Harry Hamlin sexy
and everyone's like he's so hot
oh Mario's singer you know later in life
he's actually gotten very good looking
in the beginning man it's hard to like
look at him just with your eyes because
there's so much like that is going on
with like him and Ramona cry Biermann is
on this list
yeah um
I said Eddie Judge right yes Mauricio
Mario yeah it's the same people oh
Apollo Apollo is hot yeah ex-husband
yeah all these lists are saying the same
people Todd Tucker Harry Hamlin Juan
Dixon's on these lists I'm sorry I'm not
who's Todd Candy's husband okay okay and
Edwin yeah I don't think Edwin is cute
Ellen is cute they're all good looking
guys like but then it's also becomes a
little bit like everything else like
about what's on the inside yeah because
if we're talking about like what's on
the inside you know Shane Simpson is the
hottest
no but that's why for me Frank katanga
is the hottest because it's what I'm
like it's what's on the inside and the
outside and like their contributions to
the show truly yeah like I would rather
I don't like this is gonna be such a an
unpopular opinion but like I Don't Love
Someone Like You
I don't care for like Mauricio scenes
like when other people are like done oh
that is unpopular I do when other people
are like dying over him like being high
and funny like I'm just it doesn't do it
for me but like when Frank is having
boys now you know who I think you would
consider the hottest house husband like
if inside's counted Joe Benigno
oh well sorry Joe benago is actually
extremely handsome inside and out but no
PK
oh yeah PK is history no he's one of my
favorites I thought about him but
he like yeah he's he's in there he's in
the mix yeah
I just feel like any of the husbands who
are still around his husbands are likely
good husbands that have been married for
a long time like they're good guys yeah
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah so
they're all pretty I mean like and we
and we know them for so many years like
we feel like we love them yeah
are there any husbands on the new Roni
reboot yeah are they married most of the
girls are married except for Brynn and
Jenna Lyons is married no I don't think
she is in a relationship currently but
okay and what are their husbands like
are they like young are they hot are
they Rich oh yeah yeah I'm trying to
remember everyone's
husband Aaron's husband is nice looking
size husband is nice looking
oh Uber is not married
not if she is we haven't no we were in
her apartment we didn't see a husband
um
yeah Britney's obviously not married
either oh and Uber is cousins with
Chanel I think her name is of Dubai I
never watched oh no way yes they kept
calling each other cousin and I was like
is that like a colloquial term or are
you actually cousins and I believe they
are actually cousins oh that's cool yeah
hmm
so yeah it's a good marriage there are
there's it's a married mix on new Roni
that's good yeah anyways Bryn's got
her well I mean I feel like also
answering Mauricio was just like kind of
the go-to answer if it means that she
actually has a crush on him if I've
learned anything about Brynn just based
on like social media it's that she's
like doing the most trying the hardest
and so she wants to like appeal to the
fans like Mauricio is like such a you
know basic answer yeah I think but it's
also the truth it's also the truth yeah
yeah yeah
that Andy like made it a bigger deal
than it is for now yeah yeah
and now we've said it are you ready for
our next story yeah Kim Kardashian skims
soars to a four billion dollar valuation
which would give Kim a 500 million
dollar windfall the curvy reality TV
star turned business Mogul shapewear
brand skims well that's mouthful what
about just skims raked in 270 million
dollars in its most recent funding round
to lift the company's valuation to four
billion dollars Kim said on Wednesday
um skins largest shareholder is Kim she
has 35 stake in the company according to
Forbes that means that um this would be
about a half a billion dollars worth for
her bringing her net worth to 1.7
billion dollars skims's new valuation
makes the company she co-founded twice
as valuable as Legacy retailer
Victoria's Secret which sales dropped
six percent last year and has a market
cap of 1.6 billion dollars when you
think of skims's like number one
competitor do you think Victoria's
Secret no but that is a very good
comparison and to me feels more
analogous than Spanx
um see I don't I always consider skims
and spangs to be like the two we know
yeah what is each other no I just want
to see you spanx's valuation but you
know what skims was reminding me of
because I've been shopping a lot at this
brand okay yeah but it just uh spanx's
valuation is 1.2 billion oh wow but
Spanx is one oh no it's not just one
category never mind no they've closed
swim skims reminds me a lot of Norma
Kamali
in terms of what like just in terms of
the breadth of what they do and also the
fabrics and like it's like stat It's
Fashion but it's also basic basic simple
things because I've been shopping a lot
at Norma Kamali for
um pregnancy stuff and I'm like I feel
like this is stuff that I should also or
could be getting at skims skims should
also really do a maternity collection
like all the like bump suits and stuff
they do have a maternity tab on the site
I have one of their um
their little rompers but it's like not
my favorite thing that I got it okay
um very interesting I think the journey
and like the um
Skyrocket to fame of skims is so
impressive especially when you think
about you know the beginning kimono yeah
I think you think about everyone else
like who's trying to like turn a product
line from what they're famous for it's
so hard and even if you can launch have
a successful launch and product and you
send it to everyone everyone wants to
try you know what your new thing is but
like to have returning customers who
like literally integrated into their
lives every single day it's a really
massive
no for sure and I think it's also a
lesson to like anybody who wants to
launch a brand like Kim had a few flops
before she like really kimoji
yeah like when she was just selling
things that were so like inauthentic to
her brand and then she like really
leaned in like shapewear her curves
that's what she's known for like her
style her body and like how she looks
the way she does in clothing like it was
really a perfect
um
representation of who she was and up
until that point it felt like some of
the things she was doing were like a
little bit inauthentic yeah also there's
talk that maybe they'll take the company
public so that would be like a lot of
money for Kim should we buy some skim
stock I think I would
I would too well you can't buy stock if
it's not public right no until so once
once once it goes public you could buy
the stock
interesting no it's so impressive
and I love skims like I'm literally my
I've been wearing the skims wrap for
like a week and I own a lot of stuff
from there and it's really it is that
[__] like it is yeah it is and I
actually do think the Victoria's Secret
comparison is a very good one and there
was a gap in the market then no yeah and
it's like I feel like we all bought
skims you know to support Kim and just
to be like oh Kim has it I have it and
then we all kept buying it because it's
excellent it's excellent agreed and the
cream Rises
are you ready for a little more Biz news
is a little a little bit more Biz news
that's brought to you by fashion pass
yes
we've been fashion past girls for years
now and if there was ever a time to sign
up for fashion pass this is it we know
everyone has a million weddings
vacations this summer and fashion pass
is perfect for that because you get
unlimited rentals so you can swap out
your pieces as many times a month as you
want because you know you're only going
to wear that wedding guest dress once or
think about all those vacation outfits
that you buy and you only wear once and
you take a picture and it's such a waste
it's you know waste of money you know
it's not very sustainable but fashion
pass is here for you they have all the
Best Brands like good American for love
and lemons beckon Bridge show me your
Mumu our favorite and so many more and
that's what I really feel like fashion
pass is set apart from other clothing
rental companies like the clothing is
cute like I don't know why that's so
hard for people like it's contemporary
it's stuff that you can shop you know
currently it's contemporary stuff it's
really good brands and you're saving so
much money because you're not buying
clothes all the time the pieces that
retail there for like 200 to 600 you're
getting an insane value Jackie and I are
both on the trendsetter plan so we get
four clothing items per order and we can
switch them out as often as we want the
shipping is super fast they take care of
dry cleaning you just have to send it
back in a pre-labeled bag and when
you're done you get to choose new items
it couldn't be easier and if you love
something and you want to keep it you
get a huge discount from buying directly
from Fashion pass it's anywhere from 30
to 60 off we do have a discount code for
you guys it's the best discount they
offer and you're not going to get it
anywhere else so make sure you go to
fashionpass.com toast and use code toast
at checkout you'll get 40 off your first
month so you can try it for just 49
that's unlimited rentals for just 49
with code toast at fashionpass.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace
Squarespace is the place for everything
websites it's the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time all in one place and
all on your terms so if you want to
create a website be it for your business
if you're creating a side hustle it can
be really intimidating to start a
website because it's you know more often
than not requiring like some sort of
computer science degree but Squarespace
is the best platform it is so easy
whatever type of website you're trying
to create they have amazing templates
amazing tools you can you know have
custom merch you can sell your products
in an online store which can be really
difficult to set up in terms of like
accepting payments and stuff but
Squarespace makes it so easy they also
have really flexible website templates
you can get started with one of their
professional website templates with
designs for every category and use case
and then customize your look update your
content add features to fit your unique
needs
you also can drive sales and engage your
audience with the Squarespace email
campaigns so you easily easily collect
email subscribers on your site and build
connections and repeat business through
regular updates
so uh whatever the reason you might be
wanting to start a website there's never
a bad time and Squarespace will do
everything for you and it couldn't be
easier so head to squarespace.com toast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain using Code toast
that's squarespace.com toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain using Code toast
Claudia you're welcome our next story
Netflix has gained almost 6 million new
subscribers since cracking down on
password sharing this irks me I'm going
to tell you why Netflix's recent earning
report revealed the streamer gained a
whopping 5.8 million subscribers in the
second quarter of the Year variety
reports this boost in users brings their
Global subscriber total to 238 million
marking it an eight percent increase in
subscribers year over year
so as we all know password Netflix is
narking on all of us and I'm really
struggling
yes because I'm not home right now and I
can't use Netflix because they think I'm
just like password sharing I already
said no it's me I'm on vacation they
gave me three weeks and now my vacation
is up they said and I can't do a
vacation again no it's a faulty [__]
program because yes I understand like
they're running a business and for so
many years everyone there was like a 35
people on One account okay I get it you
need to crack down in some way sure but
this is full of flaws like first of all
I travel with a Roku in my um suitcase
at all time so when I'm on vacation and
I'm at a hotel that doesn't have I just
plug it into the HDMI and this is gonna
create a huge problem for me for people
who travel for work a lot of hotels have
Netflix and you just like log in or what
about airbnb's VRBO like everybody is
always logging into their streaming
services at hotels and
any you know rental home that has an uh
an Apple TV or a Roku this creates a
problem this creates a problem people
vacation for more than three weeks
people travel for work for more than
three weeks like what is going on yeah
and like the thing is my Netflix profile
like is me I'm a paying customer we have
a big family plan and like we're all
connected through a lot of TVs but like
we are
the people who are the customers like
it's not like you know I got somebody's
Netflix password 10 years ago and I've
been holding on to it like it's like
even for someone who's following the
rules if I can verify that I got the
code that you sent like then I should be
able to get into my Netflix account yeah
if it's yeah okay so people who are
annoyed who are trying to scheme the
system can't fine but paying customers
even having trouble unacceptable yeah
they crack down too hard that yeah they
cracked a little too close to the Sun
and like you you log in in so many
places now you log in you have like TVs
in your house tablets iPad login on
computer logging on your phone plus if
you have a family plan it's like maybe
they should let us know what the exact
number of logins per profile you can
have and then maybe I would tighten my
yeah no I think about how many places
I'm logged in right now I have my iPad
when I travel
um I have my TV here I have my TV in the
living room I think of all the places
I've never logged out of my Netflix from
you know like random airbnbs and stuff
it's really annoying it's really
annoying I guess it kind of illustrates
though that there's nothing on Netflix
that I'm desperate to watch because I'm
just living without Netflix and no and
now with this strike
it's not like there's going to be new
content anytime soon I guess but it's
not great timing if there was something
I really wanted to watch and I really
want I needed Netflix I might like make
a new profile
which is so crazy which is what they
want you to do which is why I'm not part
of the 5.8 million who joined this
quarter no and I think that this um
timing really couldn't be worse like
begging people forcing them to make you
know more profiles spend more money
knowing in the coming weeks and months
they're going to have no content because
of the strike so true
so what are we paying for silence
so true I'll just listen to a podcast or
something yeah maybe I'll watch the
toast I'll read yeah I'll knit
your favorite hobby
yep I'll do a mooc bong
I'll do literally anything except spend
money no it's not about the money it's
about the principal because I I
subscribe
[Music]
to every yeah streamer I'm happy to like
I want to see you support and I'm a cord
cutter so that's why I cut my cord so
that it would have the budget to
subscribe to every streamer to spread
the seed but now if you're gonna treat
me like this no not if you're gonna
treat your customer like somebody sort
of yeah criminal yes
common criminal not just a girly on bed
rest who had to relocate and it's just
trying to watch selling sunset for
Christ's sakes for crying out loud
oh
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I really truly honestly
desperately am this story is really
crazy it's a little crime news is it
taken the country by Carly Russell it's
Carly Russell
this story is wild so last week I'm sure
everyone has seen this story Carly
Russell was the missing person last week
she had was on the phone on the highway
she pulled over on the side of the road
because she saw a toddler just like
walking along the highway and she got
out of her car to help the toddler and
she went missing yeah and it was just
like the saddest craziest thing ever you
know I think some of her belongings were
on the ground next to the car and she
was never to be heard from again then
this weekend Carly turned up at her
house like a few I don't know maybe it
was three days after she initially went
missing and now cops are saying that
there's no proof to her abduction story
yeah so I think when she just like
showed up at her parents house like the
immediate feeling was relief oh my God I
called you I was like we had been
talking about the story I was like oh my
God like they found her and but also
like the toddler you know there was kind
of this missing piece yeah and it's like
okay we're so relieved and then I feel
like it took everybody a second to get
past like the relief phase to be like
okay so what happened you know she just
like showed up I don't think she needed
medical attention and everyone was like
okay who's gonna say it like
this is a little weird you know like
there's no explanation for anything yeah
and then other stuff has started to come
out now about her like Google searches
and little searches leading up to her
quote-unquote abduction she searched the
movie Taken looked for one-way bus
tickets to Nashville I think she
literally searched how to abduct
yourself yeah though she literally
searched like how to go missing without
anyone knowing like it was you know
quite incriminating evidence and the
police did a p uh press conference last
night being like this is a hoax and
everyone was like what yeah they
revealed at the press conference that
there's no proof to her story they
stopped short of accusing her of
maliciously lying instead questioning
her mental state but said that they were
eager to speak to her again however
she's not participating in further
interrogation her parents are said to be
shielding her from the interrogation
they said we have asked to interview
Carly a second time but have not been
granted that request as you can see
there are many questions left to be
answered but only Carly can provide
those answers the family well right now
in her mental state because of trauma
she's ready to talk that's what we've
been told
well if this is in fact a hoax which the
police believe it to be
um I'm sorry there are consequences for
wasting police resources in time for
people who actually need it and then of
course you know the larger issue which
is like
it's so hard to get attention when
someone goes missing so many people go
missing all the time you had this
national news coverage and you were
lying like the implications
of that you know that you there's not a
you know uh you can't
you can be arrested for that no like you
should be and they're like you are a
disgrace yeah and it definitely you know
will probably make other people question
other things in the future which it
should not right but unfortunately it
might but do you know how many women go
Miss again don't get the coverage like
that like yeah especially black women
like girl like come on
I it's so
it was such a weirdest story and you
know what it's it kind of reminded me
and I have to credit um Heather McDonald
called her Carly Smollett yeah I've been
seeing the comparisons because when
Juicy smiley
had this thing happen
there was like a brief period where
nobody wanted to say it but they were
like something's not adding up here and
no one was gonna be the first person to
say it because like you know okay but I
never I never felt that way about this
case no when she came home okay and
there was just nothing
I think everyone had that moment they're
like well this is bizarre because like
what happened like there was this you
know we found out the second she got
home and it's like okay what happened
and then nothing silence yeah
so everyone was like okay
toddler at risk
well thank God you know but it doesn't
make it better
yeah
and I feel like you know human
trafficking is such a topic of
conversation these days and so this
really struck a chord with people this
story and it's like you could see you
know it's it's horrible every like
anytime someone goes missing but like
this woman was trying to help a like a
toddler a toddler and all these other
cars hadn't stopped and the one like
right just and then you see pictures of
her and she's like this really young
beautiful girl and
every element of this story was like
really designed to like hit home for a
lot of people for whatever reason and it
became huge news and it was fraudulent
yeah I really would like to understand
what she was trying to do
yeah
well I assume there will be a
documentary about this I know but I'm
sure it's already in the works I know
but she need like she needs to shed some
light on the situation just out of like
sheer curiosity because like if you want
to like leave town you could always
leave
yeah what were you trying to do
right like maybe she has demons she's
running from like I don't know yeah
it's been a crazy roller coaster this
journey
yeah and then why come home
she kind of successfully abducted
herself yes yes that's true like nobody
was thinking anything until she showed
up right
I don't know it's just this story is
crazy to me nobody is and I'm so
confused yeah so I you know what I just
I'll wait for the documentary because I
hopefully it'll answer some of my
questions so how can she just like
decline to be interrogated again like I
know like it's not really like optional
girly like
get back in there yeah no didn't she has
committed a crime I think if they open
up like an official like if they press
charges against her for like wasting
police resources then I do believe she
doesn't have a choice
got it but you can I guess you can play
the fifth it's your right to remain
silent yes yes but you still to go down
to the station yeah then they can try
and persuade you they said that she
declined to be interviewed again
right like as if it's um
you know option for an interview for the
New Yorker it's not optional yeah no
comment
right
um all right well I guess we'll we'll
see what happens I'm sure more stuff
will come out yeah so those are the past
five stories feel as though you needed
to know them
our second to last episode of the week
tomorrow's episode will be recorded
right before I
oh man excuse me am I gonna throw right
before you burp right before I head to
Boston for Luke Holmes I'm so excited
like literally I've been to like
thinking about it all week like this is
gonna be so much fun I'm so sorry that
you won't be joining us I'll stop
talking about it sorry I realized what I
did there it's fine I'm disassociating
so if you want to keep talking I'm I'm
not no it's okay I'm not here okay it's
okay
so I can come back now you can come back
get jacks he's coming back okay okay
um that was a great episode love you Jax
I'll see you soon I'm gonna put on like
a little bit of a face for the move bomb
for the mukbang yeah of course yeah so
we'll we'll figure out a timeline
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know everybody on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
practicing more podcasts can be found so
it's Spotify public radio I already
guessed all the places review about a
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow love ya bye
love you bye